اعلان من الرئيس التركي ثم تاكيد من موسكو
بالموافقه على تمديد العمل باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه لشهرين اضافيين فما هي
مسارات السفن التي تنقل الحبوب من موانئ
اوكرانيا للعالم تنطلق السفن من ثلاثه
موانئ اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود وهي
موانئ يجاني واوديسا وتشورنو
قبل انطلاقها من اوكرانيا من قبل ممثلين
اوكرانيين واتراك وامميين تسلك السفن
ممرات امنه عبر البحر الاسود وتتم
متابعتها لضمان عدم تعرضها لاي هجوم ويعمل
مركز المراقبه في اسطنبول على مراقبه
السفن بالتنسيق مع دول المعنيه والامم
المتحده عند وصول السفن لمضيق البوسفور
التركي يتم توزيعها على الموانئ التركيه
وتخضع لجوله تفتيش جديده لتتحرك بعدها الى
وجهتها الاخيره
بعد عوده السفن فارغه يتم تفتيشها في
الموانئ التركيه قبل ان تسلك الممرات
الامنه عائده الى اوكرانيا في التاسع
والعشرين من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي
علقت روسيا مشاركتها بعد هجوم تعرض له
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي يستانف العمل
بالاتفاقيه بعد اعلان موسكو انا حصلت على
ضمانات مكتوبه من اكياس لعدم استخدام
الممرات الامنه لاغراض عسكريه
الاتفاق على تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه جاء بعد تهديد موسكو بالانسحاب
منه اعتبارا من يوم غد بسبب عقبات امام
الصادراتها من الحبوب والاسمده
وشملت قائمه مطالب روسيا اعاده تشغيل خط
انابيب ينقل الامونيا الى ميناء اوكراني
على البحر الاسود
ورغم ان هذه الصادرات الروسيه لا تخضع
لعقوبات غربيه فرضت بعد الحرب في فبراير
شباط 2022 فان موسكو تقول ان القيود
المفروضه على المدفوعه والخدمات اللوجستيه
والتامين شكلت عائقا امام الشحنات وتتهم
روسيا مسئولين اوكرانيين في مركز التنسيق
المشترك الذي يشرف على تنفيذ الاتفاق في
اسطنبول تتهمهم برفض بحث اعاده تشغيل خط
انابيب الامونيا نشير الى ان اتفاقيه حبوب
البحر الاسود تتضمن تامين صادرات الحبوب
العالقه في الموانئ الاوكرانيه على البحر
الاسود لمعالجه نقص الغذاء العالمي الذي
ينذر بكارثه انسانيه وقد سمح الاتفاق
بتصدير اكثر من 30 مليون طن من الحبوب من
اوكرانيا منذ بدء تطبيقه في الاول من اب
اغسطس الماضي وهما يكفي لاطعام 150 مليون
شخص لمده عام واحد بحسب الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو